So now we will look at one of the so
called LRU approximation algorithms,
which this one is called NMRU or
Not Most Recently Used.
And it's trying to approximate
the performance of LRU but
with less activity on his.
So again, NMRU stands for
Not Most Recently Used.
The way it would work is that we would
track which one block in the set
is the most recently used one,
at any given time.
And then,
when we need to replace something,
we pick a block that is not the block
that is the most recently used.
So, for example, we can pick
randomly among, the other blocks,
but we save the most recently used
block from eviction from the cache.
So how do we track which block is MRU?
Let's say we have an N-way
set-associative cache and
we want to track the MRU block for
each set.
We need only one MRU pointer per set.
We only need to know
which block has been
the most recently
accessed one in the set.
So for example, if we have a two
way set-associative cache,
we only need one bit to tell us which of
the two is the most recently accessed.
If we have a four way set associative
cache we will have a two bit pointer
that tells us which of the four has been
the most recently accessed and so on.
Compare this to N LRU counters that
we need percent\g in a four way
associative cache, we would need
a two bit pointer for NMRU.
We would need four two bit
LRU counters to maintain LRU.
So this policy keeps N
times less state for
an N way set associative cache,
then the true LRU policy.
It turns out that this policy
works reasonably well.
It does have a hit rate that is
slightly lower than a true LRU,
but if this is what it
takes to make our cache
go from two cycles hit time to one
cycle hit time, It might be worth it.
A disadvantage of this policy is that
although it prevents the most recently
accessed line from being evicted,
it doesn't know what the order
is among the rest of them.
So there is a truly least recently
used block among these three for
example, but we don't know which one.
So we will pick one of these three and
might select something that is
not the least recently used.
So although this works well because the
most frequently accessed thing well be
saved in the cache, it is slightly
weaker than through LRU because of this.
Because it doesn't know which
one is the really recently used.
So what we might want to have is
a policy that is still simpler than LRU
but keeps more track about what's
less recently used than the MRU